deux temps
[Musique]
je suis nicolas ellis je suis le chef
d'orchestre et directeur artistique de
l'orchestré symphonique de l'agora ainsi
que le chef d'orchestre assistant alors
qu'est-ce symphonique de québec
mme également engagée pour faire 6
répétition avec orchestre symphonique de
mcgill pour leur concert avec kent
nagano à la maison symphonique
travaillant pas dit j'ai vraiment hâte
de pouvoir voir ce que lui va aller
chercher de leur caisse puis si ce que
lui vos remarques et du travail que moi
j'aurais fait avant lui ça s'annonce
pour être quelque chose de très très
enrichissant je pratique le piano depuis
j'ai 7 ans et pendant que je faisais mon
bac en piano à 9,6 de montréal je
développe un intérêt pour la musique
orchestrale donc j'ai rassemblé des amis
organisent des projets qui avec le temps
ce une passion que c'est vraiment
développer
[Musique]
promis je finis ma maîtrise le mieux
c'est de retourner à mes guides cette
fois ci en tant que à être engagés par
une mission bien préparée l'arc est
vraiment c'est vraiment trippant
rick yannick nézet-séguin j'allais voir
beaucoup ses répétitions alors qu'elle
se métropolitaine quand j'étais étudiant
ça fait déjà quelques concerts qu'il y
en ait qui l'orchestré métropolitain me
contacter pour être chef invité yannick
vie c'est quelque chose de vraiment
exceptionnel
[Musique]
mon objectif c'est pas du tout d'être un
deuxième yannick né des personnes
différentes mais même si on partage
certains points en commun mais moi je
pense que j'ai mon chemin afin pis seul
l'avenir nous dira quoi savoir si on a
une répétition avec l'atelier lyrique de
l'opéra de montréal
[Musique]
et on va présenter un concert autour des
airs d'opéras de mozart
lorqu'elle symphonique de l'agora existe
depuis cinq ans et a pour mission
d'organiser des concerts au profit de
l'organisme en terre puis l'idée
derrière si c'était tout simplement un
désir d'implication sociale puis de le
faire à travers la musée
donc cette année on a fait un concert au
profit des porteurs de musique qui on
envoie des musiciens dans des endroits
comme des sens psychiatrique des
personnes âgées etc
[Musique]
le concept extrêmement choyé de pouvoir
sauter d'un projet à l'autre que ce soit
avec l'orchestré symphonique de québec
où je travaille comme assistant depuis
trois ans ou à travers un différend
concerne ce que je veux en tout cas
c'est pouvoir livre la muse et de
pouvoir continuer à vivre des
expériences musicales avec des
orchestres de très haut calibre
autour d'un répertoire que j'adore je me
considère vraiment chanceux de pouvoir
le faire déjà maintenant j'espère juste
que ça va continuer de se développer
puis que je pouvoir multiplie ses
expériences le à l'extérieur
[Musique]